bonjour jérôme blanchet gravel
bonsoir merci beaucoup c'est vrai que
c'est le soir pour vous bonjour on va
parler de la situation sanitaire au
canada et de ces restrictions dont la
principale on l'a entendu ces deux taxes
et maintenant et les personnes non
vaccinées c'est une mesure un peu
radical non
ben oui je pense qu'on peut dire ça
derrière le terme de contribution santé
donc c'est un
c'est un terme à ces polices pour finir
en désigner une taxe ce qui est tout à
fait discriminatoire je pense que tout
le monde peut s'entendre là-dessus enfin
le gouvernement va s'en défendre c'est
donc c'est pour fesser pour pénaliser un
finalement les les citoyens qui n'ont
pas été assez obéissent 1
il ya une certaine résistance vous
l'avez mentionné donc ça fait quand même
polémique mais c'est quand même une
réaction assez faible par rapport à ce
que ça peut représenter comme précédent
comment est-ce que le gouvernement
québécois on arrive à de telles mesures
est ce que il ya une réelle incitation à
faire chez les non vaccinés quelle est
la proportion d'ailleurs d'aider non
vaccinés au québec
c'est pas beaucoup en parlent de 10 %
seulement de non vaccinés le québec a
l'un des taux de vaccinations les plus
élevés dans le monde donc ça peut
surprendre parce qu'on pourrait se
satisfaire d'un tel succès d'une
certaine façon mais le gouvernement
legault en fait appeler vraiment la
politique que du risque zéro et on en
veut toujours plus on est dans une sorte
de spirale
infernale
et il nous parlera le groupe bcc a
appelé aussi une politique du
bouc-émissaire depuis le début de la
crise on cherche à trouver des gros qui
sur lequel déversé ne peuvent plus
station de ne pas voir le plein contrôle
sur la situation au kosovo des puces a
été des comics tous ne respectez pas
assez des règles dans cette année des
voyageurs
les vacanciers les écoles et ceux qui
faisaient la fête et maintenant juste
pour don vacciner donc
on cherche toujours un groupe sur lequel
ses sa a racheté la musique a cité
finalement des mesures sanitaires parce
que la part des gnons d'accord pour le
pas au complet composé est d'autant plus
que dites moi si je me trompe la
situation s'améliore également au québec
elle s'améliore mais faut dire quand
même que le système de santé est
extrêmement fragile au québec traité
fragile donc c'est ce qui permet au
gouvernement le goût de justifier des
mesures aussi sévères pour le mentionner
il s'en vante lui-même le premier
ministre legault d'appliquer les mesures
les plus sévères en amérique du nord
d'ailleurs le 31 janvier dernier le
québec a été le seul état en amérique du
nord à interdire toute forme de
rassemblement pour le nouvel an dont on
est vraiment dans
90 la société distincte au québec dans
cette côte de dire sur le plan sanitaire
donc même pour vous dire il ya même de
plus en plus de québécois qui qui ont
déjà quitté le québec pour les états
unis pour vivre finalement plus
librement certains songent à le faire
aussi actuellement
peut-être que d'ici
2023 quelques milliers de québécois
auront quitté le territoire pauvre des
états américains plus c'est ça plus
libéraux comme l'exode a pleuré léger
terrain d'autres vont mexique donc c'est
quand même on est quand même dans
quelque chose de nouveau et qui est un
peu
ça fait le même assez fort on est
vraiment dans un état où là le risque
zéro est devenu un pull à la religion
d'état et le québec à ma s'enfonce de
plus en plus on a peur de vivre on est
vraiment une société aseptisée où tout
est présenté comme un risque sur le plan
sanitaire c'est une société qui de vie
qui s'en va finalement une sorte de
puritanisme alors il y a aussi d'autres
restrictions qui entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui dans tout le canada a priori
qu dites moi si c'est le cas
interdiction de d'acheter de l'alcool ou
du cannabis
sans présentation d'un pass sanitaires à
partir d'aujourd'hui pourquoi pourquoi
avoir décidé cette mesure
comme une fois c'est une punition assez
symbolique parce que ya pas vraiment
d'études qui montrent que l'interdiction
en fait je vais je l'expliqué c'est que
les personnes non vaccinées en effet
n'ont plus le droit de
rentrer dans les succursales de la
société des alcools du québec donc plus
spécifiquement à ces personnes n'auront
plus droit d'acheter du vin de qualité
dont qui pourront seulement acheter de
la bière et du vin de table dans les
épiceries donc ils ont encore fait le
contraire en fait on a du mal à
comprendre quel est l'intérêt sanitaires
d'une telle mesure
ben il n'y en a aucun comme je dis on
est vraiment dans la punition donc des
citoyens qui n'ont pas voulu se plier à
la volonté du gouvernement legault son
tuteur sont simplement puni c'est une
sorte de punition digne d'un jardin
d'enfants si vous voulez
c'est vraiment l'état maternelle donc
c'est là pour les pénaliser tout
simplement il ya évidemment aucune
aucune aucun impact sur la place anita
et même que les employés des succursales
en question de société alcools du québec
n'ont pas être vaccinés jusqu'à présent
dont vous voyez les incohérences dans
les employés n'ont pas être vaccinés
mais doivent demander des passeports
vaccinaux aux clients donc vous voyez
effectivement sur le plan sanitaire ses
rôles et dans le même temps jérôme
blanchet gravel le canada dessert en
pole et les restrictions
n'ont pas vraiment de relâchement le
canada est vraiment l'un des pays les
plus anita reste au monde avec
l'australie c'est un des pays où il est
le plus compliqué de rentrer quand on
revient de
voyage c'est un pays duquel on ne peut
pas sortir non plus par les airs sans
être vaccinés même les étrangers s'ils
veulent retourner dans leur pays doivent
avoir au moins deux doses pour quitter
le seul canadien donc ça aussi c'est une
mesure et sur le plan juridique est
assez incroyable certains juristes la
défendre parce que bon apparemment c'est
toujours qu'il s'agit de protéger la
santé des gens apparemment c'est comme
au dessus de toutes les lois mais non le
lien aucun relâchement le canada
vraiment
s'enfonce dans le risque zéro la
population adhère à ces mesures elles
contestent ou pas
le degré de d'adhésion est
particulièrement fort au québec au
canada
peut-être un peu moins mais globalement
aussi
cela dit depuis quelques semaines je
voudrais qu'on commence à sentir une
certaine fatigue le gouvernement legault
va faire face à une certaine
satisfaction ça commence
les partis d'opposition québec ont
toujours été du côté du gouvernement ou
à peu près là où ils ont critiqué de
manière très timide mais on sent un
début de contestation québec qui
pourrait s'amplifier dans les prochaines
semaines on va suivre cela merci
beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir veillé si
tardivement pour être en direct avec
nous sur rt france ce matin